هذا موقع انا نيوز العسكري الروسي ان قوات
فاجنر تمكنت من عبور نهر بخمودكا الذي
يقسم مدينه باكموت الى قسمين وانها تتقدم
باتجاه مركز المدينه في حين قال عضو مجلس
اداره مقاطعه ذا فورجيا المواليه لروسيا
فلاديمير فان الجيش الاوكراني يقوم بنقل
قوات من محور زابولوجيا باتجاه بخبخ
تاكيده رصد عمليات نقل مجموعات كبيره من
القوات الاوكرانيه
منزابولوجيا الى منطقه باخموت وان الجيش
الاوكراني يحشد نحو 70 الف عسكري في الوقت
الراهن على كل محور زابولوجيا
قالت استخبارات وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
ان القوه الاوكرانيه وخطوط امدادها الى
الغرب في باخموت لا تزال عرضه للمحاوله
الروسيه المستمره لتطويق المدافعين عن
المدينه واضافت في تغريده الله على تويتر
ان استراتيجيه القوات الاوكرانيه الدفاعيه
تجعل من الصعب على قوه فاجنر مواصله
هجومها من الناحيه الغربيه